Contamos con el proyecto,
contamos con la ilusión,
contamos con las ideas,
con los equipos para avanzar más y más rápido.
Y tras esta última legislatura,
pues además contamos con la experiencia de cooperar
en 1 gobierno de coalición
y yo estoy convencido de que habiendo hecho las cosas
muy bien
en circunstancias extraordinariamente complejas.
Efectivamente coincido con Yolanda.
En esta ocasión lo vamos a hacer aún mejor.
Vamos a hacerlo aún mejor
porque nadie sabe lo que VA a ocurrir
durante los próximos 4 años,
pero las oportunidades en el horizonte son inabarcables.
También lo son los riesgos y las incertidumbres.
Lo que sí que puedo garantizar
a los españoles y españolas
es que España no se VA a detener ante nada
ni ante nadie.
Ninguna crisis internacional
VA a apartarnos de nuestros valores,
de nuestros principios,
ni tampoco del proyecto modernizador.
Estamos aspirando a liderar el partido socialista
y también sumar.
Los españoles y españolas
Han decidido con su voto
que el próximo gobierno sea 1 gobierno de coalición,
progresista y de avances,
4 años más de progreso y de convivencia,
así que pongámonos en marcha. Muchas Gracias y adelante